was surreal and kind of daunting
stepping onto such a major you know past
an ensemble that it has but it was it
was exciting you know I'm really
flattered that Josh thought of me for
this role and that I had Lizzie to play
my sister and I think you know those
characters really complement one another
and really balance and each other so we
did the characters justice at the end of
the day do you know I think these
specifically Marvel fans I think are
real enthusiastic you know I've been to
comic-con and seen them there too and
you know they're just you know it's a
real beautiful positive energy that they
have yeah I think he's grateful and it
was kind of the reality there was quite
humorous because he'd actually be in a
onesie
he's put a mocap which is like black and
white kind of pajamas
with a stick with two red bubbles
bubbles at that without the use but
nonetheless beautiful performances that
you know Island would be looking at him
and we realize in front of one I think
the best villain to take on the Avengers
you